okay next question David will the 2020
election lead to violence in the streets
that could be interpreted a bunch of
different ways if your question is with
violence by who my guess is the question
right there could be violence in the
streets if Trump wins and there could be
violence in the streets if Trump doesn't
win and the violence in either or both
cases would be by different people I
mean I guess let's just sort of go
through it because this is so often
asked if Donald Trump wins will there be
violence from leftists in the streets I
think it is very unlikely I mean okay we
cover left-wing violence to the extent
that it exists most of the political
violence in the United States violence
over politics is right-wing we did a
story earlier this week about it will
there be violence in the streets if
Trump wins from trumpets celebrating uh
I don't know probably not I don't I
don't I don't think so I think the most
likely source of violence electoral II
would be if Donald Trump loses and gins
up anger among his base over a so-called
fraudulent election I think that's the
most likely scenario to lead to violence
in the streets and I hope it doesn't
happen and I think it's really important
you know when we talk in the lead-up to
an election about we want the highest
voter turnout possible part of that is
the more people are engaged with the
democratic process the more difficult it
is to sort of fire people up along the
basis of these fraud claims if everybody
knows they voted and there is sort of an
easy way to corroborate that the results
that we've seen are the results that
people believe are the correct ones
it makes it much more difficult for
authoritarian leaning folks like Donald
Trump to actually fire people up and and
and in in more significant ways I think
it's also important when we talk about
securing the election to understand that
on the backend one of the negative
impact of not securing the election can
be more of an opening for violence in
the streets the the likes of which I'm
being asked about here so when we talk
about voter suppression when we talk
about foreign interference when we talk
about all of these things the more
secure we all believe our
elections to be the less likely it is
that there is going to be that sort of
violence if and I hope it really doesn't
happen Donald Trump loses in November of
2020 but claims that he was robbed in
some fraudulent way and his supporters
group go crazy and get out on the street
some portion of them will take the bait
from him and will do it but if the
majority of the country if a plurality
of the country understands that no we
have a democratic process and it worth
reasonably well there is no cause for
violence here that is a great insulator
from that type of violence I hope that
there will not be violence in the
streets and if there is I know we have
the resources to quell it responsibly
and respectfully people who are just
exercising a right to speech should not
be manhandled there shouldn't be
violence done against them by law
enforcement that's extraordinarily
important to remember as well but those
who are violent on the streets do need
to suffer the consequences of that
because we should be against all of
those forms of violence no question
whatsoever I want to hear from you about
it what do you think is the most likely
scenario to lead to violence in the
streets I think again the most likely
scenario is violence from the right over
Donald Trump losing and claiming that he
didn't and saying that he needs some
kind of support in staying in the White
House which I do not believe he would
ultimately be able to do let me know
what you think we've got a great bonus
show for you today become a member at
join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get instant access to the world-famous
bonus show